[Music]
no trying to compete with Beyonce we saw
her last time we were at the Grammys she
needed to give us a hug we had to back
away if it wasn't to two bucks
Beyonce totally slayed at the 2018
Grammy Awards alongside her hubby jay-z
and their six-year-old daughter Blue Ivy
the Carters were dressed to the nines
looking chic as ever in a
black-and-white color scheme the power
couple both wearing black Beyonce
rocking a hat a high slit gown by
Nicolas Gibran and 6.8 million dollars
worth of Lorraine Schwartz jewelry
meanwhile Blue Ivy looked ever the
sophisticated young lady in a polished
white ensemble she even adorably shush
to parents while Camilla Kibeho was
speaking on stage swag
the famous fam has been livin it up all
weekend Saturday B and J attended Clive
Davis and The Recording Academy's
pre-grammy gala where jay-z was honored
with the salute to industry icons award
the stars praised his impact on music
jay-z was such a big part of my career
you know and I think that honoring him
is the best thing ever you go Vegas back
here too